okay so um our
final talk of this evening and also of
this conference is
by rule of peters from 23ai as we can
see on the screen
um be sure to stay tuned after
the talk for a bit because then we'll
have the closing notes from our to
um uh from mataj and
marisha i'm having a little bit of
blackout here
um so be sure to stay tuned after the
rule of thug
and well i'm very curious to hear about
uh how you watch millions of trees with
python and what kind of impact you can
make
with that i would say the floor is yours
if you have your screen to share you
should be able to do that as well
great yes can everybody see this
i think so it looks good on the the
floor is yours
great so good evening everyone i'll try
to make this uh
quick and snappy i'll try to stick to 30
minutes uh
since i understand i'm in the last one
of the conference
and there's some some other nice things
going on after me
um so i'm going off i'm the city of 23
where we built kind of technology to
look after the planets mainly trees and
other vegetation
and we do this continuously all over the
world and mainly to
take action against climate change and
as well make better
decisions about our shared environment
so i'll start telling a little bit about
the problem we're trying to solve or at
least have some impact on with 23
and then i'll talk a little bit about
the specific domain of satellite imagery
and how we work with it and also what
role python can play in it
uh and then also show some examples of
some of the stuff um
we're doing uh as well as a little bit
of our own ongoing research uh
and also if you are so inclined to to
work in this domain yourself
i hope uh some of you will be after this
talk uh giving some pointers to like
where
you might want to look first so
i'm very fortunate to be part of an
amazing team we're around
seven now we started two years ago and
as you can see we have a quite strong
data science focus
we mainly work with large corporates
ngos since we kind of believe those are
the kind of entities that have the
largest impact on the client climate and
on the planet for better or for worse
and where we also want to kind of steer
things in the right direction
um so about me very shortly i started
out as computer scientist at the
university of amsterdam
then i moved for 10 years plus to social
science more
specifically anthropology and found my
way back to
software development i used to be based
in sweden for for 10 years plus
where i worked for a couple of ai
startups and also started startup
and then when i moved back to amsterdam
i joined 23
but i've been there now for six months
uh so on to the the real stuff and bear
with me this will be kind of five
minutes of
um that like the bad stuff that's going
on
uh and then it will be 25 minutes of
like what is the amazing stuff we can do
about it
um so there's five minutes of doom and
then 25 minutes of
positivity um so i would start like
talking about how amazingly beautiful
forests and trees are but let me just
say that like
keeping forest intact is literally like
a prerequisite for our own
survival as a species as we all know our
planet is under pressure
um previous speaker already talked about
deforestation
uh forest fires as well which are
increasing together with kind of extreme
climate events and so these have really
a large impact
kind of on the society as well as our
economy and so
yeah we believe that kind of we really
should try to to hold this as much as we
can
and so forth already half the size they
they once were
um and ongoing deforestation which is a
nice word for destroying
entire ecologies emits about 15 percent
of
global greenhouse gas emissions which is
quite large as a portion
um so so why are forests so important
well
first forests create oxygen we we breed
um they're also one of the major sources
of
our food and water they regulate the
hydrological cycle which basically is a
fancy word for saying
they produce terrain we need for our
crops
and also they are kind of the largest
diverse biome we have that give like
life to about 80 percent
of all the non-human life on land so
that's a
quite important part of our planet to
kind of keep intact
and so at 23 we think that one way to
try to tackle this issue is that we need
more data-driven information
which then can help like making better
decisions about our natural resources
as well as more transparency and so by
applying
machine learning to high-resolution
satellite imagery
we essentially call create what we call
them planet intelligence
which are insights into both the
quantity and the quality of our natural
resources
um and so some last maps about what's
going on before we go into more detail
um here you can see like our current
forest
in dark green and then the more semi
forest in light cream
and you can see they they cover quite a
large portion of our total landmass
and the actual forest go over around 20
of total uh land so if we're 23 we
always say like we work with forest and
that can seem quite niche but like if
you
imagine that that's 20 of the land
there's still quite a large portion of
the world and this is actually what you
can see
uh through our friends the global force
watch if you want to learn more
uh what is going on with uh
deforestation um which is going quite
rapidly
uh and it's something like i strongly
believe that technology is kind of one
really important piece of the puzzle as
but it's not like
sufficiently enough um and
this is a book i really recommend anyone
um
working in technology to to to read
seeing like a state
by james scott and it's essentially
about
um simplification and standardization
and when we create big systems
as many of our like software developers
do we electrocute systems
that have some effect in the real world
um often there's all kind of unintended
consequences which we could have
actually thought about a little bit
better beforehand and so one example
that's quite relevant here
i'll skip to quite large quotes like
this part is the important part it's
something
vincent earlier got talked about like
active empathy
um and it's essentially it's about like
active listening right so it's about as
technologists
uh we like to always jump into problem
solving mode
but this is about like trying to take
the time to understand our users and
problems first a little bit
more design thinking approach um and
this specific example is about the rise
and the fall of
german scientific forestry like relevant
to the story i talk about
in the late 18th century where um
like a lot of forestry and forest
companies thought okay like trees are
quite wild and these ecology is like
they're really not manageable
we should be able to do this more
scientifically and more standardized
and so essentially what started to be
done is really like
the first just turned uh which we have a
lot of high in holland to the right you
can see these nicely plant
forests but essentially initially it
worked really well um
but force started producing more timber
and it was especially more
manageable and more um measurable
but already quite soon after like
another fourth cycle
um like trees essentially started dying
out
and you had this concept of vulgar stab
and
what started to come around in the
german speaking world so just to say
like
sometimes like the cure is worse than
like
what's going on so we should be quite
careful that when we put kind of quite
powerful technologies
into the world and really think about it
but also especially get
the people who were supposed to help as
much involved as possible
as early as possible so almost at the
end of the drama story
um forest fires another major
contributor to climate change which i
will
uh go a little bit more detail in um
they're on the rise um they have a large
impact on
greenhouse gases like simply sat like
trees killed by fires will decompose and
release carbon
and they will also not be existing
anymore so we'll not be
sacrificing uh carbon either fortunately
this looks quite horrifying but a big
part of this is also part of a natural
uh
cycle of of burn and recovering um
except maybe in in like the us and
australia and russia not so much and
amazon um but it doesn't look like as as
nasty as you see here still it's a
process we want to
halt as much as we can where it's needed
so for the good news then
uh what can we do about it well first of
all tracking fires from space as you
could see before it's actually pretty
straightforward
uh we can identify trends quite well
they're pretty massive
and so we can see them actually from
satellite geometry at like 800
kilometers away
uh here you can see an image from the
copernicus
installation from the european
commission from california in 2018
and since they're like satellites of
many different instruments
we can also look at different bands like
multispectral
imagery as you see here and this allows
us even to look through these clouds but
here you
can't really see what's going on but
using this kind of more
multi-spectral data we can look through
the clouds and really see more of the
scale of the fire
so that's all nice and good and we can
of course analyze this automatically
but we don't really want to track
wildfires only we want to also prevent
them
so with with 23 around a year ago we
really started looking at like the main
causes of forest fires
and so we found out like just one
example of like a use case
we found out that power lines
surprisingly are actually
one of the main causes of forest fires
and this is more specifically because of
the interaction of overhead power lines
with trees
uh and just in california for instance
like there was this massive
fire which was caused by um forty
percent of the area burned was actually
caused by
um just power lines interacting with
trees like trees falling down on power
lines or
like storm or things like this and so
that's a huge problem
and it should also be quite a solvable
problem
um so what then about satellite data
what can satellite data do to to help so
let's take a step back
um and also what makes it possible to to
to especially now
have such a large impact that we can
really like bring this to and halt
um so what has been chasing in in recent
years
is that the number of satellites being
launched is really really increasing
um so that's essentially what you can
see and with the number of satellites
also the number
of instruments and also the the the
price so here you see the
different launches going on in last week
actually
um and this means also that the price of
being able to hitch a ride on one of
these
launches and put your satellites there
together with the size of satellites
going down
so from the size of a bus like a double
decker bus to kind of the size of a
little
something that fits in your hand almost
these cubesats
and essentially like quite cheaply get
your satellites into the
space and then use it for for good um we
don't do that ourselves but we have a
lot of partners we work with
um so here's an example of the kind of
imagery we look at
so here you can see 30 centimeter
resolution now you can see
quite a lot of things from the three
level human eye um
but this is the the are the three rgb
channels so that's quite
usual like what we're used to see but
there's many other spectrums we have
we saw barely the multi spectrum range
which is useful for understanding the
health of vegetation
and so here you can see all those
different spectrums
but we also see other things like
radar imagery which is useful to look
through clouds and also at night time
so even if there's clouds like at
rainforests are generally quite
cloudy we can actually look through the
clouds or when there's no light
other things that that are kind of
feasible within the last few years
is that there's many more companies
available
um that after satellites that allow us
to do quick revisits
so we can like really from day to day
see how
particular places in the on the planet
are kind of changing
which you can see here um and finally
like different resolutions so here you
can see the
harbor of rotterdam so two and a half
meter resolution
so quite blurry um you can see some
things
but then this is the difference you get
with like more commercial uh
like data available from three from two
half centimeter
so you can even identify the individual
containers or cars and things like this
um so this also helps us then to label
things
uh much better so what we've been doing
over the the past two years then
um is basically that we have
a lot of data from our partners we work
with um which can be things like um
you know infested trees in which we have
more than a hundred thousand trees
around the world
where we know the exit coordinates and
the times um but also climate data and
whatnot
uh and on the other hand we have
petabytes of unlabeled satellite imagery
so there's a big unbalance in in a sense
like we really
have like normal computer vision
problems there's always an imbalance but
this is like an extreme imbalance
right um so
what can we like what does this data
then consist of like first of all when
we look at satellite data
we want to look at the location like
where do we want to get a
image from the time what is the date and
then we want to look at things like
what portion of an image is covered by
clouds like maybe we want to find only
images that have
less than five percent covered with
clouds um and then we see of course if
they're available
or not and then we do all kind of
post-processing steps
since there's a lot of noise and
satellite data generally
do some other stuff train the model and
and win
um so this is essentially how this looks
like here we have the
sentinel uh constellation which is a
um it's a 10 meter resolution
um and just to kind of compare with kind
of normal computer problems that just
if we would take like here we have
holland we have like three tiles or
images make up like the entirety of
holland
um just if we were take like holland and
we take like one image a day for an
entire year we already have
data that's about three times the
largest open computer veggie data set in
the world like open images
um so this means we really like have a
lot of data to work with
um and
what you can see here is that our
internal um
like um repository so here you can see
to the left
you can see us loading in some some kind
of trying to query some satellite data
with like
some simple line of python code so we
can
identify it by tells we can see the
cloud cover etc
and on the right we can do the same by
specifying a particular area of interest
um so that's quite quite quite useful um
then of course once we have that image
and you can yourself download these
things easily like sentinel
10 meter resolution is freely accessible
for anyone um but then we want to of
course download it and then we can plot
it and see how this image
actually looks like um so that's great
that's a quite
relatively easy way that there's a
post-processing step missing
but it's a relatively easy way of
actually acquiring satellite
data and images of the world so anyone
can do this like for particular problems
you're interested in
and that's quite useful so what then we
do with this data like how do we
make models that we can do this for the
entire world
and this simplified technical pipeline i
won't really go into much detail
but we have like different providers
looking at data from we have our own
data pipeline we have a model zoo where
we have different models we're training
and different um versions
and then that makes it up into like a
dashboard which we sell as a
subscription service for our clients and
an api
and a lot of that is like powered by
python simple
quite simple python code um and so the
kind of techniques we then use
is uh on the one hand we have top left
lens segmentation which is like the more
standard stuff
um anyone working with machine learning
knows the kind of u-net
approach so you have like an auto
encoder um
or like residual connections so we
create segmentations of like let's say
stuff like land cover which means with
particular areas or like forest or if
they're urban or if they're water
then we can also put that into what you
see bottom left into like an lstm or a
transformer
like the kind of stuff raza and vincent
loves to play with like the transformer
stuff
and so we can create like time series uh
things we can do like a change detection
um other things we can do
top right is more the classical computer
vision stuff where you do bounding boxes
and we can
count things um and then because we have
so much
unlabeled data we and partly what i did
a lot of my phd work on
was on unsupervised models so we can do
unsupervised learning semi or
semi-supervised or
self-supervised like there's different
ways of doing that but
essentially what you can do is like you
take an image which you don't know
anything about
but you can turn it into data by just
doing something smart with it
where in this case like intuitively you
can just say
like widths of these pieces a b or c is
the kind of missing puzzle piece
which you would fit into here and
clearly that would be b and that's a
nice
you know learning task you could create
from any kind of data
and that lets you create like really
nice representations
of data without needing any labels and
this allows us to kind of work with like
two factors less
data um which is or labels i should say
which is quite useful since uh
essentially getting labels can be quite
costly
i'll try to speed up a little bit so i
can reach my
time of time other things we do is stir
imaging so we take like
multiple images from different angles
from the same place
and projecting these onto each other we
can get 3d curate 3d maps
um and so we can do things like the
heights of trees or or
cities up to accuracy below one meter
um this is kind of some smarter
approaches if you're really interested
to do that
the link is there it's kind of a way how
you can do sift
type features but you can do a neural
neural network style with some
craft convolutional hats in the middle
so that's a nice nice paper um
we do things like with my my previous
field startup creative ai
uh it's a lot of like generative models
so we can take
freely accessible data on the top right
and we can try to transform it into
commercial
data and this is not a real example like
this is too perfect but it's the idea
that you can turn the top image into the
bottom image with some
you know generative models essentially
like the gun type models or whatever you
want to use for it
um and so how we do this we use like one
of these models also freely
uh accessible as code in pytorch and we
try to see this as a time
series problem where we try to up-sample
different resolution imagery
uh with every time step a little bit so
two times
up to the level where we want it um and
from that we actually get a retreat like
this so we get like
the left image so it's very blurry and
straight from the satellite
and we can upscale it to something where
we can actually see more clearly what it
is and also
especially um limited so we can see okay
this is clearly there's
on the top there's a there's a palm
there together with some other kind of
bushes and some other bombs to the right
so it's quite useful um other examples
where you see houses that are a bit more
clearly
identifiable and roads um
and so what allows that to do is like do
less with more right which we would say
and that's quite important because we
um in our case like creating labels from
let's say
a tree that is distressed or sick can be
like a two week
like a two day hike right into the
middle of nowhere um so we want to limit
this as much as possible or when we
ask our customers or partners we work
with to do that for us or people who we
hire in the field
it really has to have the largest impact
possible so for that we use active
learning
which essentially is the way you have
training data you have your machine
learning model that you train on it
then you have some unlabeled data which
you do run inference on
and through some by easy and learning or
whatever you want to
use it you can try to find the examples
that look just purely random
but you can estimate what the neural
network knows the least about
and try or have the most impact on the
training regime
and then ask human annotators to to
label that essentially
and so that's what you can see uh here
this example another library
um which you can freely use and play
with from friends servers with element
ai
we also do a lot of interesting stuff
with satellite imagery um
so there you can do like bayesian
inference type stuff which means you
just run
a train model multiple times and you
just add drop
out everywhere and you essentially uh
approximate
like a magnesium neural net without much
uh
yeah without much work not super
efficient but it works
and you can get nice probability
estimations of uncertainty
uh so that's what you can see here you
have to the left you have some
predictions
of um of trees like a
sick trees in this example and it's
zoomed out heavily so there's a very
large plot of land
and then to the right you can't really
see it well but here i put the arrows
you can see little red
dots that's the top top five or k n
whatever clustered
top most uncertain parts
and then we can ask people to
specifically go there or if we can see
it ourselves on the satellite imagery if
it's like higher resolution
we label that and we add it into the mix
and we can kind of reach you
and label that again
so machine learning we use fast ai uh
very high level lets us experiment
rapidly and easily
we do pytorch as well with lower level
and we have a repository set data
might be renamed and once kind of the
domain
yeah bugs and stuff and it works
smoothly uh i worked out we actually
would love to
release this publicly uh allowing anyone
to kind of
apply fast ai style easy to use neural
network code with just a few lines
being able to use satellite data for
hopefully good things
and why we love this is because it's
like layered everything is customizable
pluggable
it has a lot of best practices in there
so it just has like really good
standards and we try to follow this for
satellite imagery as well which like
it's quite tricky um but that's the id
so that
even with limited knowledge of satellite
data you should be able to come in
and do a lot of like useful things with
it
then other things that are great there's
the link for people who don't know it it
has like custom
transformations and easy two-way
callbacks so you can put all kinds of
like um
callbacks uh on it instead of having to
change code we can essentially
patch functions and we can just override
it with type annotations or whatnot
um example here is for instance a get
data loader
it's essentially it goes on to the by
torch normal data loader and you see
here after batch train after that's
valid
you see some custom transforms so we
want to the training
part of the data set we want to have
some augmentation
and the valid we don't want this then we
have some other stuff on there
and this is done how we can use it
so we have all kind of um
other um custom
callbacks here so we have filter
predicate which lets us filter
um images if there's no data or if
there's a lot of nouns
we can do all kind of after item stuff
as well which is a way where we can just
do
extra transformations and that's a quite
useful way of like overriding existing
functions without too much work
um and here you see how this done looks
like with more the standard
fastai type code um so that's quite
useful
um other things we can do is what you
see here this is from the standard
fasterite documentation
you can do um custom type annotations
and
and also for instance this can call the
named
types of name dancers and through type
dispatch which is what you see here
you can essentially have the same
function flip all r flip that right
um but you don't really have to worry if
you use it like what your particular
type is just so you have instead of
having to rename or do all kind of like
if-then-else statements about what
the type isn't type checking you can
just create different functions
with the type uh annotation and it will
just run that function
if you're uh if it's the correct type
so and an image will have different
transformations than for instance a
bounding box right so that's what you
can see to the bottom you can just do
whatever your your type of data point is
and you just flip it left right and you
don't have to worry
like what is the type and it just works
uh other examples here
i'll skip this one but here in some of
our code ourselves
you have a transformation so there's a
custom transformation which
encodes data so it does some let's say
augmentation encode
and it also changes the type so it turns
the set map into a
transform segment and then we have a
simple decode
which is automatically run when we do
the transform backwards
um and it just checks if it's a transfer
set map it will decode it
but it's not a transfer setmap then it
will not decode it so that's another
nice way
of using kind of type annotations to
make things easier
serialization is quite useful um i'll
skip this example but it's
if you don't know dill try checking it
out it allows you to essentially also
pickle entire classes and functions
within your
your dumps so
the problem is if you would run this you
would have
functions uh function pointers and your
functions wouldn't be
uh pickled only the links to the
functions but in our case we have all
kinds of custom functions we just want
to package up into the model definition
automatically
when we export it so people can use it
and that's essentially what you then can
i can
see here i'll skip the code but it's
essentially just a way
of being able to wrap all of that up
even the functions don't exist
uh or you don't have access to that they
will just pick it up within
the model definition uh somewhere i only
have five minutes so
also go a little bit faster i'll skip
this part this is just what what are
kind of best practices for debugging
basically when you debug your models um
we learned a hard way to always make it
easy to inspect things visually
which i think is underappreciated um
so we always like to look to like look
at top losses but here for instance we
automatically plot augmentations and we
can see just sanity check things
visually a lot
um other things we do is we can
automatically
inspect model uncertainties so to the
bot the top of it
um you see actually uncertainty map and
you can see which models are more short
than the others
the bottom you see like a histogram plot
so you see that
the right model these are three models
kind of in the vertical axis
so you see that the all right model has
a more normal distribution which means
it's more spread out and better trained
more generalizable
which you can also see in the
predictions they're a bit more robust
other things you can do once you have
uncertainty estimates models
also per classes you can instead of this
when you would kind of merge these
predictions as an ensemble
you could also take down certainty
predictions when you
arc max things uh and then you can take
the new accountant you get much more
accurate
predictions um you can use it to debug
things class probabilities
and then i'll skip a lot of the rest
which basically means inspect things
visually because metrics
don't always tell the truth and be deaf
is what we're using
which we wrote a blog post about which
you can read
yourself on our medium channel but
basically how we use it
it's a way where you get like high
python notebooks without the benefits of
a normal
ide so here you see repository where
essentially
i buy the notebooks some people might
hate notebooks they're messy they're not
they're only good for experiments we
embrace it so it means we can iterate
quite quickly with them
for my notebooks we automatically create
libraries so these are full python
packages
so it's the same stuff and we can do
this through all kind of
annotations so you see the expert export
annotation here which means that these
functions will automatically be turned
into library functions with the benefit
that once we compile it and push it
to github things are actually
automatically compiled into
documentation as well so here we have
automatically heroku documentation
created
and we have even things like interactive
maps and stuff are all automatically
correctly created
so that's quite quite useful um
and then other things which and be deaf
which is from the makers of
fast eye also allows you to do is kind
of do proper ci cd stuff
so you have um through github actions
you can still do
search and all kinds of tests in your
notebooks with the benefit that you
don't only have just testing your
notebooks but you also have all the
documentation
and easy readable stuff in there so
instead of working more
like this would be the usual thing where
research and experimental might be some
more notebook type stuff and production
is more libraries and
separate code we really embrace it and
we get more
agile type software development
and so we use libraries like this for
this most of them are covered already
ammo flow for experiment tracking and
models um and then we use reddit for as
a high
throughput io um a database
mainly for large scale inference when we
have to kind of take a map of the world
have to package stuff into smaller
patches we can predict on
and do all kinds of fancy stuff with it
and put it back get it all aggregated
back into a map of the world
and so there's all kind of bottlenecks
cpu gpu memory uis
and so it's kind of modularized event
task management system
uh and it makes use of redis so
kubernetes for all these kind of things
would be nice
if you have like individual images but
if your image is essentially one large
image
this is a we found a little bit better
approach
so final use case done i'll skip to
example it's basically this
preventing force fires by um
overhead power lines we essentially just
have this
input different input styles uh we have
our
our kind of models that create a
vegetation map
and then we have other models that do
power line inspection
and we create this dashboard which is
the product we actually have for utility
clients
which can do all these things it can get
hotspots it can do all kinds of other
things
um yeah and that's it i'll skip the rest
um it basically just shows a little bit
more if you want to get started yourself
but that will be in the slides
so just like if you want to get started
with some easy library
there's eolearn there is google earth
engine which lets you do kind of simple
remote sensing stuff in your browser
there is
other things that are useful there are
data sets available
so all these links will be in the slides
there's some other resources
way too much to cover but if you want to
get started with some some code or some
tutorials
um then there is a nice paper if you
want to really get started with
uh more the ai approach to climate
change this is a kind of nice
um introduction in your paper which
covers a lot of different problem sets
and or the kind of techniques that might
be useful for it also available with
climate change.ai
then if you're a software developer you
just want to build websites and do
a lot of other useful stuff not
necessarily as data sciencey
um there's climate action to tech also a
slack group where a lot of us
are hanging out and helping each other
and trying to come up with good things
we have like you can go to bitly23ai
where you can see your kind of a twitter
feed of some of the stuff and some of
the news that's going on
with uh 23. but essentially
we're hiring we're looking for more
people to join the team
um if you want to do your own startup
since i'm very much in the startup space
there's three new funds just launched
last week or this week um it's pretty
crazy blue dot
actually all of also which will be
launching as an investor that
will be announcing that quite soon uh
for our seed rounds
but also prime and lower carbon capital
um so there's a lot of climates related
impact funds um that are there so if you
want to
run your own startup and do some of this
stuff like the best time is now
and that's it so not sure if you have
time with stover questions
but i can always see you on discord
well thank you for this interesting talk
but with a very clear mission and also
uh well a nice technical overview of the
way you approach these
um i see two questions i think we have
time for them uh
before we go to the closing notes so the
first one by
core is uh the question whether you use
a cnn to create the point cloud or do
you use more
classical uh cv techniques use both
um i mean for some baseline we always
like to do like classical remote sensing
as a baseline because like there's no
point to do fancy models if it doesn't
improve things
uh and mostly that's related to data so
neural networks deep learning
uh are are great but there needs to be
kind of a data requirement that that
fits that complexity
and so we use both we use like dense
convolutional mapping
it's pretty pretty standard these days
but yeah there's a lot of extra fans so
what we're looking at more is multi-task
learning
so i covered a little bit about the kind
of embedding techniques we're using
so the idea is that we have specialized
small tasks
with our heads on a larger model and so
we can have specialized training data
but still get the benefit of combining
all that data together
with specialized uh training regimes
like check out the stuff by andrei
karpati for um
uber or sorry tesla if you want to know
more about that they're kind of i think
state of the art in multi-task learning
right then a second another question by
carson he says monitoring deforestation
is sort of like writing tests
it's only useful if people uh pay
attention to it
so how do we get it to lead to actual
decrease in deforestation activity
any thoughts i mean that's what
everything so that's actually a big
challenge for me when i really wanted to
do something
impact-wise with ai and why actually for
a long time i didn't do much ai
i actually moved away from ai for a year
um doing hardware stuff
because i felt that that's where i could
have an impact on the grounds
um because yeah you're right like ai is
just a tool and then the tool has still
to be used like it's great that you can
see where deforestation is going on
but then that still has to be
transferred into actual action um and so
for that
we we basically we we work with partners
like we work with large ngos and large
corporates that essentially do these
things but they do it very
manually um and then we just help them
do that
more efficiently and at scale but that's
right like you should start from the
problem in the actual
challenge and not so much from you know
creating nice virtual technical models
of things which might look good but
don't
as such bring any change